foreign
schools in Clark County Rancho High
School is proud to hold on to its
Hispanic Roots by teaching a colorful
and cultural tradition of course we're
talking about Ballet Folklorico now as
we learn in our next story each region
of Mexico has its very own spin
photojournalist Henry takai shows us how
young people are embracing this age-old
tradition
[Music]
is a type of dance
we use the term Malay not for American
Ballet but because we're a group so a
lot of times in when people think ballet
they think ballerinas but we use the
term ballet because it means that we
dance together as a group
[Applause]
folkotico is a collective term
that covers the entire region of Mexico
and each individual states have their
own style this is actually our 20th year
but most of my students start from their
freshman year not knowing anything
we've spent a lot of time perfecting our
dances during summer and the school year
that we've been in so far the steps in
general I love showing people how hard
we work the dedication we put into
everything and I earn a family with this
and it's just an amazing experience
connects us to our culture and our
history and our past it also teaches a
lot of skills that you need in life it
seems it teaches teamwork it teaches how
to get along with others it teaches you
know patience everybody can dance but
you just have to have the patience with
yourself and the practice time
[Music]
well it's National Hispanic Heritage
Month and here at 8 news now we're
jumping into some of the history the
stories the cultures and the
contributions of Latinos from our
community and all across the nation
catch Hispanic heritage special this
Saturday at 6 30 right here on Channel
8.